derrière ces grillages s'opère une
véritable métamorphose terminé le style
des années 60 caractéristiques du musée
franck perret c'est un bâtiment
contemporain qui prend forme sous les
mains de ses ouvriers
nous avons choisi de prendre un matériau
qui soient facilement sur sable donc du
bois et plus en accord avec ce qui s'est
passé le 8 mai 1902 donc on a proposé
d'utiliser une technique japonaise qui
s'appelle chaussures guy ban ki et le
brûlage ces techniques de brûlage du
bois qui permet de noircir le bois de le
rendre plus résistant aux insectes aux
champignons et au vieillissement
quelques 15 entreprises et une vingtaine
de commandes est affective sur un
chantier de rénovation qui tient compte
de l'existant un bâti de 120 mètres
carrés qui a des atouts indéniables et
des contraintes il ya une toute petite
extension qui fait 14 mètres carrés qui
est posée sur l'ancienne rampe tout
bêtement et on s'est contenté de greffer
sur le bâtiment une ce qui sera la
future galerie 2
d'immersion d'entrer dans le musée on a
modifié la façon de rentrer dans le
musée c'est toujours par la porte à peu
près à l'endroit où l'on rentré avant
mais on l'a dit steve bruce distribution
se fait de façon un peu différente
la transformation en profondeur est
également dans l'agencement dans la mise
en valeur des pièces du musée mais aussi
et surtout dans le symbole
le musée devient mémorial nous avons
décidé de faire évoluer le nom en
conservant la mémoire du fondateur col
ferret en ajoutant le terme mémorial de
la catastrophe de 1902 qui permet de
ramener le musée sur une histoire
humaine une question de mémoire de
toutes ces victimes qui ont disparu à
saint pierre en 1902
tout est basé sur les objets de la
collection et les objets déposés par
l'état dans le cadre d'un des fouilles
archéologiques et nous allons présenter
uniquement des pièces authentiques qui
raconte la vie vue humain de la
catastrophe
le coût total de ce chantier de 1
million 500 mille euros
ils devraient être terminés fin avril
pour une ouverture prévue le 8 mai autre
symbole